So in this part of the course, we're
going to be looking at the introduction to Lumen,
where we're going to break down what it is and how it works.
So let's get started.
First up, many will ask, what is Lumen?
So Lumen is Unreal Engine 5's fully dynamic global
illumination and reflection system.
It's designed for next generation consoles, default
global illumination, and reflection system.
Now, keep in mind, it doesn't
have to be just for games.
This can also be done for Final Pixel,
as well as VR training or simulation.
So it works pretty well now and works really great
with those venues.
Not dependent, unlike ray tracing,
on having the latest machine, but higher settings
are GPU expensive.
So you have to keep those things in mind.
And I'll point those out later on in the course.
Lumen renders diffuse interreflection
with infinite bounces and indirect specular reflections
in large, detailed environments.
At scales ranging from millimeters to kilometers.
So it's really efficient.
It really tries to help you get the best look
that you can.
And I'm going to walk you through some of the tools
and how to get things in the right direction.
So also, what is it?
Now, many people will ask, how does this
work compared to the old versions of Unreal,
if you are used to or understand
the old versions of Unreal, where you would bake your light.
But in Lumen, we're getting an update on the fly.
We're getting our global illumination
and the photon calculations back at the camera being sent back
there, so that we're getting a nice, clean, updated,
realistic scene.
So diffuse indirect lighting, Lumen GI, light bounces
and color bleeds is what it represents.
So Lumen also provides infinite diffuse bounces overall.
Unreal Engine 5's Nanite visualized geometry
allows geometry to be much more detailed.
And Lumen achieves a full resolution shading
while computing indirect lighting cheaper than before.
So it actually is really efficient.
Sky lighting is solved as part of Lumen's final gather
process.
It includes sky shadowing, allows indoor space
to be much darker than outdoor lighting,
and have much more of a natural effect.
Lumen also provides a lower quality global illumination
for lit translucency and volumetric fog.
So we've really thought about how to optimize this and get
it the best possible tool for your lighting needs.
And it works really, really great.
Lumen emissive materials, though, can be expensive.
And we're going to go and take a look at Unreal.
I'm going to point out a few things with that,
as well as we're going to look at the settings
that you have at your fingertips in the project settings
and in the post-process volume.
You see, emissive materials propagate light
through Lumen's final gather with no additional performance
cost.
It's pretty awesome.
But you can run into trouble when
you have small pieces of geometry that you want to glow.
There may be noise, and it may not
be accurately represented.
So there's a limit.
So you have to keep things in mind.
And you can see the note here.
It says, however, there's a limit to how small.
So again, emphasizing that, be careful as you do that.
You might want to actually have a physical light attached
to an object, or maybe even have
some sort of pre-baked system in there and brought in
and lighting things via vertex and via texture
if they really are small and really need to be accurate.
But for the most part, you can use Lumen
when it comes to emissive materials,
as long as you keep those things in mind.
So Lumen solves indirect specular or reflections
for full range of material roughness values.
And it works really well.
Now, you might get noise every once in a while dealing
with your roughness and your materials.
That is always something to keep in mind
when it comes to updating GI on the fly.
But you have several CVARs, and you
can see in some of our documentation,
that will help clean up some of that.
And I'm going to point you to some of the CVARs
that you can work with.
Diffused GI and shadowed skylight
can be seen in all reflections.
And Lumen reflections also support clear coat materials,
which is a really added plus, because then you're
getting your updates on the fly.
And you can control your materials
and make things work really great.
So what does it replace working with Lumen?
It replaces skylight with AO or unshadowed.
It replaces screen space global illumination.
It replaces ray tracing GI and third party GI solutions,
such as NVIDIA's RTXGI.
So let's talk about how to set it up.
And I'll also point out about getting things
to be emissive in your scene.
So we have a scene here that has Lumen.
This is the one that we used earlier.
But let's talk about how to set up a scene.
Now, we have project settings here.
This is where we're going to initially set things up and get
it in the right direction.
So I'm going to open this up.
In your project settings, you want to scroll down and go
to Rendering.
In Rendering, we're going to scroll down a bit more.
And we're going to make sure that we
have a dynamic global illumination method set to Lumen.
Now, it should be on by default.
But there are a few things you do need to edit.
And also, if you're grabbing something from the marketplace,
I'm going to point out some things to keep in mind.
You'll notice a reflection method right now is Lumen.
Now, in the post-process volume,
you can change some of these if you need.
And I'll point those out later.
But for now, we're going to keep things all Lumen.
We have a ray lighting mode here.
And you'll see that it says Hit Reflection or Surface Catch.
Hit gives you a bit more accuracy.
And Surface Catch is a little bit lower in quality.
So you have to keep those things in mind, what you want
and what kind of hardware you're working with,
as well as what you have in your scene.
You'll notice our shadows are always going
to be virtual shadow maps.
That is what works with Lumen and is the ideal setting
to set.
You'll notice, too, our software ray tracing mode.
We can do detail tracing or global tracing.
One, obviously, is cheaper than the other.
Detail tracing is a lot higher than global tracing.
And you can choose that based, again, on your scene
and what you're working with under the hood
in your computer.
You'll notice also we have Use Hardware Ray Tracing
when available.
This is important to turn on if you have the ability
to be able to run that.
You also want to make sure under Hardware Ray Tracing,
you have Supports Hardware Ray Tracing.
Also, this needs to be turned on
if you have it available.
It is very helpful to keep these on
because they will then support,
as you're working with Lumen,
and get things to calculate and update on the fly
and give you the best possible results.
Now, you'll hear me mention this again in the class,
but I'll emphasize this now,
and I'll repeat myself later.
When it comes to Lumen, Nanite, and virtual shadow maps,
they're like the three musketeers.
They really were made to work together.
So it's very important when you are building your scene
to not rule out working with Nanite
because it'll give you the best, most realistic geometry,
but also virtual shadow maps will complement
that realistic geometry to give you
the best possible results for your shadows.
And then Lumen will give you
the best possible results for your lighting.
All those work really great together.
Now, we talked about emissive.
If you go over here,
you'll see there's some emissive lights.
These are pretty decent size,
so this isn't going to be too much of a trouble.
But if I had a smaller piece of geometry
and I want to make it glow,
the accuracy might be an issue.
You'll notice we are getting a little bit of noise here.
You'll notice from our point light here,
we're not getting much noise, it's pretty clean.
But over here with this emissive material,
we may be getting a bit of noise.
So what you can do in that case,
you'll notice even if I increase the size,
the noise may persist, not necessarily go away.
There are CVARs to be able to clean some of that up.
And I can also go into the material itself
and decide that I want to edit some things such as roughness
and a few other items.
And I'm going to repeat myself later in the course.
So as you lower your roughness,
you can see some of the noise goes away
as you keep it clear.
But as you increase the roughness like it does with,
like what happens with ray tracing,
you can end up getting a bit more noise.
You can also flatten it out
and make it so there's even no noise whatsoever.
But as soon as you hit that middle ground,
just keep things in mind with your materials,
how you want that material to be represented
because noise may try to creep in.
You also want to make sure
that you're using Shader Model 6.
Now this is more important
if you're getting stuff off the marketplace,
because by default Shader Model 6 should be on.
If you're not sure how to get there,
let me show you how to get there in Unreal.
In Unreal, you go to your project settings,
you can simply type in SM6,
and you'll see that Shader Model 6 is ready to go.
Now I'm going to turn mine on and it's going to reboot.
And when it does, that's going to actually give me
the best possible results for my virtual shadow maps,
as well as going to make it so that my visualizers
for Lumen, Nanite, and virtual shadow maps
are working correctly.
So let's go ahead and turn that on.
So I've turned that on and it's restarted.
Awesome, that's great.
So we got things working in the right direction
with our Lumen scene.
Now we talked about in the project settings,
how we have to make sure Lumen is on,
that we can control a lighting mode,
software ray tracing mode,
and we also make sure that things are supported
for how we're ray tracing.
You'll notice in here that you also can,
and you'll notice, what I mean is you can notice
in my notes that it says in the post process volume,
you can edit some of these settings,
which is really great.
And again, also by default,
your generate mesh distance fields will be on.
Now again, if you're grabbing something
from the marketplace, you want to step through
and make sure these things are on.
Let me show you.
So in my project settings, I'm going to pop that up.
In here, I'm going to type in
generate mesh distance fields.
And you want to make sure that's on,
especially if you're getting things from the marketplace.
They may be a little bit older
and may not have these things on.
But by default, working with a Lumen scene,
these should be active.
We also want to make sure for better AO built into Lumen,
we want to make sure we are not using the old default.
To turn these settings off,
you want to go into your project settings
and you want to make sure that you allow static lighting
and ambient occlusion static fraction AO bake lighting are off.
So let me show you that.
So let's go back into those project settings.
And we're going to say allow static lighting.
You want to turn that off.
And we also want to make sure that allow ambient,
make sure it type in incorrectly.
I should say ambient, not allow on this one,
that our ambient occlusion static fraction is also off.
You're going to make sure those two are off.
In the next section,
we're going to look at quality control,
some advanced settings,
and some tips and tricks when working with Lumen.